tr it is so nice to chat with you and
get to meet you virtually i have to say
congratulations on the bravest night
this show is incredible it's inclusive
it is what the world needs right now for
anyone hearing about it in canada for
the first time can you kind of break
down what the series is all about
yeah it's a kid show um about a young
girl nia uh who is uh wants to be a
knight her dad one of her dads is a
knight
and the other of her dads happens to be
a prince and so i'm the night half of
that and uh the show kind of uh
they're like around 12 minutes each each
episode and
it's um
you know she's it's her lessons about
what it takes to become a knight and uh
through those lessons it's told in
flashback uh uh to win sir cedric uh the
player character i play
is a young kid also wanting to be a
knight so there's the you know the
lessons that nia needs to learn are
lessons that uh uh said young cedric
also learned as a kid and uh you know
and a little cedric has a
a friend a troll named grunt
and nia is played by storm reed the
brilliant storm read
and uh grunt is
bobby moynihan uh and
prince
andrew is wilson cruz and the cast has
like christine baranski
donna murphy rupaul it's a very talented
group of people that i'm very lucky that
uh i got to sneak in and be a part of
well they are lucky to have you be a
part of it because you are talented too
tr like this is an incredible series as
a queer reporter like this is what i
want in my life i want to see children
learning from a young age um about you
know what the world has to offer and
part of that is queer people we aren't
going anywhere was that kind of part of
what you really liked about doing this
series is that we are now educating
children from a young age that queer
people exist and it's okay and love is
love
well i think i mean
yeah on such a deep profound level i i
think that
growing up myself just speaking for
myself growing up not seeing myself
uh you know kids not seeing their
families uh uh represented not seeing
myself represented uh so often the uh
you know it's uh the the queer narrative
is one of tragedy that's what i saw
growing up or um
uh
that's so
i was about to swear completely damaging
and and what it does to uh uh
it's just all a lie you know it's all a
lie and so um
to show
to see just to see
kindness to see
love
is um
you know i guess it's like you can
either you you can either teach with
fear or you can teach with love and uh
and i think that
i can't imagine who i would be today if
i saw myself
really saw myself growing up
so to be a part of something
you know that it's the first of all it's
entertaining right it's entertaining i
hope it sparks kids imagination it's
it
it's a magical world of trolls and
fairies and
witches and dragons and yetis and
um so it you know first and foremost
it's entertaining and it's
imaginative and i think that uh
if some kindness can be uh gleaned from
it uh
yeah that would be that would be
wonderful as well
yeah you hit on something so important
there like representation really does
matter i think we're around kind of the
same age and i grew up also not really
having that representation on television
especially when i was young and going
through grade school and that's why a
series like this is so important i think
the first time i kind of saw myself
reflected on television was with the
show like queer spoke which was shot
here in toronto a lot of it um what was
your what was your first kind of like
you said there wasn't a lot when we were
younger growing up there was things like
will and grace and queer spoke but those
were the two where i was like oh okay
i'm not alone in this well i think uh uh
uh you're flattering me i think i'm uh
way older than you are i don't think you
are that's a lie i'm 37.
i'm 48.
shut up so i'm older i win i will i
had no idea sorry oh please please um uh
uh
i think that because of that age
difference that 10 years
it was you know before you know will and
grace and it so
i remember
uh three's company
and i remember uh
all of
the gay jokes yeah you know the uh you
know whether it was mocking or disgust
all of those kind of faces that and i'm
not blaming any of the actors in this uh
it was a different time but all of those
you know it
it was uh it was something
i just remember really
hating it to be honest and i don't uh
again i understand that it was a very
different time and i'm not i'm trying to
vilify anyone involved in doing it uh in
in in making that but it was
that was one of the things that
i remember even before i could fully
process
uh
everything for myself because i was
growing up and my brain is still
developing but i knew
i knew how terrible it made me feel yeah
um and so that was one of the one of the
many things i mean of course growing up
also uh in the aids
epidemic you know uh there was also that
narrative as well so there was disgust
something to be laughed at and then
there was death and it was uh
it's this uh it's it's really hard
for a young kid to see that and then
there's all the stuff that you hear in
your in in at school at you know
conversations that adults have that
horrible things that are said off the
cuff that just that that
that just resonate and are so uh
destructive
yeah
and that's why you show
yeah i'm sorry to cut you off no sorry
to go i started going down a little
spiraling i
apologize please don't apologize because
like that's the important thing here
like i look at the media that we have
now in the representation there needs to
be more but i look at something like
this series and even something like
rupaul's drag race like there are kids
now who are like six and are owning who
they are because they see there is a
world out there that accepts them that
loves them and that they have a family
but for you like this really is
groundbreaking this is a series that
features a openly gay lead character and
you are voicing that character it's one
of the first like what does that mean
for you to voice an animated character
and it be one of the first openly queer
characters
uh everything i don't know how else to
say it other than it means everything
and i think that's you know it's a
testament to big bad buu studios uh
uh uh rez and i uh who you know
she
is one of the co-founders uh she
directed this and you know
making
creating art to uh make the world a
better place and that's you know that
big bad boo is doing that is
you know they're the ones who deserve
the credit i think uh
because
they were
i just i i i'm grateful to them i'm
grateful that that that
uh they created this
yeah but nobody can take it away from
you either that you are voicing what you
know what i mean like don't sell
yourself short tr like this is like
historic like it's super cool
it is it is but it's i think it's i
think as like you know as an actor it's
you know
uh
as an actor there's just there are a lot
of us out there and there's i think that
when you are lucky enough to be a part
of something
it is it you know uh
especially something that's just so
moving to me personally
i don't know there's just this a real
sense of uh you know
i can't there's i don't know what it is
but it's that
it's for therapy i guess but it's just
it's that sense of god i can't believe
how lucky i am that this
that uh i was able to be included in
this
uh yeah i don't know i don't um
it is because it's it's it's just you
know
it's just it's incredibly
in my small little life it's incredibly
profound and uh um i'm it's just it's
it's nice to be part of a narrative
that's about
uh
that leads with love
you know and it's uh
and uh
especially it's just like
i don't know if it's getting older i
don't know if uh
the world is changing so much i don't
know if it's the same in canada as we
experience in the us because i don't
think you uh
it seems like uh
i don't know maybe the gras it's a grass
is always greener kind of thing but it
seems like there is a real
uh there are two factions that are just
completely grinding against each other
in such an a negative unhealthy way and
it seems that negativity seems to be so
embraced
oddly embraced lately if that makes
sense i don't know if i i don't know if
i've had enough caffeine yet
but to make sense
but uh so it's nice to uh
be a part of something that that uh
that that leads with love
and especially especially now
especially now
i don't know i don't know it's a
yeah
because
anyway
i feel i feel like i'm about to get on
this box and i have so many different
soap boxes here and different sizes that
i stand on and yeah yeah they sometimes
i stack them on top of each other yeah
yeah
i hear that listen you're part of
another incredible series you've had
such a great career like i've been
watching your career for many years now
of course people recognize you from
grace you made an appearance back uh
late last year that was
incredible like fans were so happy about
that how did it feel to come back and be
embraced and be back in that world
something i never thought would happen i
uh
it was
it again it was uh
it was it was it was a very moving
experience because we filmed on a beach
so it was it had a feeling of being a
new
experience yeah because it was
this this other world uh
and i got to see and act with these
people
and work with these people that um
are just uh are
really beautiful people beautiful souls
and uh so it was and then just getting
to
revisit i've never had that experience
before revisiting the character after so
many years
getting to say krista vernoff's words
again getting to act with ellen and and
chandra and jim and it's uh
it it was it felt like that day it felt
like just waves of
of being overwhelmed of
joy
of
uh uh linda klein who is the uh magic
between behind everything medical she
just you know she's
she's a former scrub nurse and she's
directing the some of the shows now
she's been she's a producer on it she's
been it from the beginning she's
she is all the medicine of greys and she
is the backbone of the show in so many
ways and she came to the beach that day
she wasn't she wasn't she didn't
wasn't
needed on set because there was you know
we were on a beach but
she came to spend the day and it was
just like
uh
my old makeup man even though it was
just sunblock that i used came back
out of semi retirement uh norm levitt to
to to be there and it was just uh
yeah just like
talk about you know
you know the ocean metaphor waves of
love
so it was a it was a
i'm still processing it in a way so
forgive me if my uh if my words aren't
uh exactly clear but uh
it's it was it was incredible it was an
incredible experience
i'm sorry
well yeah we were grateful to see you
back on the show and finally very
quickly
everyone loved you on the flight
attendant that show is
so great everyone is eagerly waiting for
season two i don't think you've started
shooting yet correct
no i haven't read anything yet i am
nothing yet i am like i i'm chomping at
the bit i'm chomping at the bit i got to
be patient but um
yeah so i i i don't have to worry about
uh any
spoiling anything because i i know
nothing but uh i am jon snow in the
scenario and uh uh
uh
um it's uh yeah it was
working with kaylee because that was
predominantly my stuff
it was just really exciting it was
really
i loved that kind of
i love their dynamic i love that uh
the
real difficult relationship that they
have
i love
it's just fascinating how
two people raised in the same family
with a lot of damage
are so
diametrically opposed in so many ways
and
experience things and cope with things
so differently and you think that uh you
know they would have each other you know
in a center if you would just read about
the scenario you'd think oh at least
they have each other but they clash so
much and i think it's just exciting to
play and it's exciting to
it's also because last year was a book
it was based on a book right yeah so and
that was the full novel there is there
isn't a there wasn't another one written
so they're creating this season season
two out of whole cloth so it's going to
be really i'm really excited to see
there's there's nothing like i can read
to be like oh how much is this going to
be like the book there's nothing like
that
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos